world hall-of-fame world giant blitz
chess championship that's what this is
that's a defending champion for two
years in a row but this year this year
he's going down and we begin soon as he
starts the clock
story of my life
Queen trade okay
no eat pie for you I'm a little down on
time we'll just a point about that I'm
making some quick Queen side moves I
must admit I wish I advice but
physically physically trying way to flee
chest on the planet
double okay where's this threat I
actually have to respect his chest skill
you know the castle didn't see that
coming let's take that seat bro
okay fine see well remember no shame in
bragging you bro
yeah
let's do it again oh yeah don't think I
won't always be five brother say what
we're playing this is the this is the
try to get some rest opening yeah Oscar
playing and then you play positional
chess with me pride Bishop d6 who says
it doesn't happen when you pee in cat Oh
bro yeah
castles is rough all right let's go in
for d4 let's go in put the d4 square
maxime is exhausted I can feel it can
you see how exhausted he is
[Music]
vulnerability Holmes zbg up there
don't head but the intern oh man I want
to stack on f3 so bad it hurts again
yeah c5 supporting supporting my
dominance you ever seen the rule number
2 can outplayed a giant chess now you
have where you going with that what are
you doing that's a good move
I can't do that bill lose my fishery
buddy
now I can oh yeah
sack down ties the match ties the match
with some old school flag
I was born this way he's moving so fast
it's weird UNK what are you doing I'm
gonna go check my shoe I'm gonna get you
I'm gonna get
check town population you bro so he
moved so he moved what that's ridiculous
there we go yes way that's not mate oh
that's not mate false alarm
false alarm it's not made everybody
not even close look left Christensen eat
your heart out
oh you didn't see that coming did you
that's not what isn't baby how you are
not made in the world never know jack
spinning out of resources honey me care
do not care about that check hold that
one
you
here we go I'm gonna I'm gonna flag you
so bad
this is way too much theory for this guy
this way too much theory
oh can you feel the bird
that's that vote for bunny it's
ridiculous this is ridiculous
talk about your queen side structure oh
man
I'm so tired I'm so tired right now yeah
you like that attack your word wouldn't
yeah go ahead
there's my nickname in high school two
pieces for a roof dan what they called
me
[Music]
ain't no party like a jeep file party
because the jeep final party don't stop
comb down and play moves nevermind I'm
losing it
that's it we're going to buy go into
five
Game five to two winner take all giant
chess world championship let's go Mick
seen a four it's the pawn on the
queenside damn right I have no
shame man I know you know I'm gonna
plaid the Frenchman with three names at
the world show us all the fame yes
flex the primetime game yeah he's losing
and he's getting outplayed could be the
year people this could be the year let's
act that point yo ice at that point just
like I opened that G pile on purpose oh
you're gonna Castle Wang huh yeah I
don't care I did not see that oh my god
tricky tricky frenchman tricky frenchman
rooks love the third-ranked
taking that elevator lift to the Queen
side boom I feel it whether you'll feel
it or not I feel it I feel it yup starts
in my nose and then I get bubbly chose
this is it this is it yes I will yes I
will oh man alright I still got the
attack he didn't want the exchange I
don't love it
oh man he's getting the attack
[Applause]
check
that's it the West was won by flagging
him hey but we all did good